parliamo di accesso
prima da quindi borse valigie cinture ma
anche calzature e gioielli si tratta di
categorie quotidiane afferenti al mondo
del fashion e del lifestyle oggetti
quotidiani che siamo abituati a vedere a
utilizzare molteplici volte durante
l'arco di una giornata fanno
costantemente parte della nostra vita e
rientrano nel nostro scenario quotidiano
gli accessori sono senza dubbio oggetti
con una componente estetica
straordinaria spesso sono addirittura
l'elemento decisivo nella definizione
dell'immagine di una persona
la costruzione del nostro aspetto è
un'operazione che mettiamo in atto in
pratica tutti i giorni in modo più o
meno consapevole e in questo processo
ogni oggetto indossabile quindi
dall'abito all'accessorio concorre a
trasmettere quello che vogliamo
comunicare di noi stessi
ma mentre l'abbigliamento tende a essere
sempre più basico semplice omologante è
invece sempre più forte il ruolo
dell'accessorio nell'esprimere la
personalità e quindi nel definire
l'identità di chi lo indossa e quindi
innegabile il ruolo della componente
estetica dell'accessorio come strumento
di comunicazione del set ma spesso
tendiamo a dimenticarci che questa non è
l'unica componente anzi quella
fondamentale è quella che gli accessori
sono anche e soprattutto degli oggetti
che hanno delle funzioni pratiche una o
più di una pensiamo alle spille che
chiudono cardigan cappotti oppure
cinture che sostengono i pantaloni le
gonne le borse le valigie addirittura
sono forse gli accessori funzionali per
eccellenza per definizione nascono
proprio con la funzione di contenere e
trasportare degli oggetti nella
preistoria erano i semi nell'antica
grecia le monete e così via anche nella
contemporaneità
gli accessori sono oggetti
che costantemente instaurano un rapporto
funzionale con gli abiti ed anche con
altri oggetti per contenerli per
proteggerli per fermarli per legarli al
corpo quindi le valigie per trasportare
gli effetti personali
le borse che si portano insieme ad altre
borse o che si appoggiano sopra le
valigie quindi gli accessori si
interfacciano tra di loro e si
interfacciano necessariamente con il
corpo lo vestono lo contengono
vi si appoggiano lo sostengono per
questo motivo l'utente con la sua
ergonomia con le sue esigenze e centrale
nella progettazione di un accessorio e
sui due universi dell'utente e delle sue
necessità deve sempre di più vertere la
ricerca la ricerca che è il punto di
partenza per progettare degli accessori
veramente funzionali nel design
la ricerca è fondamentale ai miei
studenti chiedo sempre di guardarsi
intorno di identificare aspetti nei
quali prodotti esistenti sono carenti e
soprattutto di identificare delle
esigenze che l'offerta che attualmente
sul mercato non soddisfa ancora per
sapere per esempio come sarà la borsa di
domani
basta già oggi guardarsi intorno non
troveremo chiaramente già quella che
l'estetica della borsa di domani ma
sicuramente ne troveremo le funzioni
perché le funzioni della borsa di domani
sono le funzioni che le borse del
presente non sono in grado di svolgere e
proprio dalla ricerca dall'osservazione
che nascono le idee innovative
ne sanno qualcosa le povere signore del
mio quartiere che soprattutto quelle
anziane tutte le volte mi colgono sul
fatto mentre le osservo quando si
aggirano con le loro borse per strada
queste signore per lungo tempo mi hanno
scambiato per uno scippatore perché mi
vedevano sempre con gli occhi puntati
sulle loro borse quando lo incrociavo
per strada per fortuna poi hanno capito
che sono innocuo e non avevo nessuna
intenzione di rubare le borse quindi
osservando però queste queste signore ho
raccolto molte informazioni preziose per
il mio
perché è proprio la ricerca delle
abitudini quotidiane di un target il
primo passo del percorso progettuale
indagando che cosa le persone devono
trasportare quale mezzo utilizzano per
spostarsi come indossano le borse quante
volte le aprono come le chiudono quale
mano utilizzano per aprirle e chiuderle
quindi studiando il consumatore nel
quotidiano si individuano delle nuove
esigenze e cercando di soddisfare queste
esigenze
prendono avvio e progetti e straordinari
ci sono infatti anche accessori che
esulano dal contesto del quotidiano sono
degli accessori estremi i virtuosismi
stilistici che sono straordinari per
definizione in quanto pensati per le
occasioni speciali per esempio i
gioielli da indossare alla prima della
scala
le borse da red carpet all o le borse da
sfilata in questi accessori non c'è
nulla di ordinario i materiali sono rari
e preziosi
le lavorazioni sono artigianali
complesse
i volumi sono estremi quindi borse e
gioielli qui devono rientrare
perfettamente in in un'estetica che
l'estetica della collezione dove
accessori abbigliamento si completano a
vicenda per creare un total look che
deve essere forte e coerente e quindi
questa è la dimensione della creatività
pura
qui i limiti legati ai costi di
produzione si dissolvono le dinamiche
commerciali sono cancellate da quelle
che sono le esigenze di immagine e il
prodotto quindi arriva ad astrarsi dal
quotidiano fino a diventare quello che è
un sogno irraggiungibile ma anche gli
accessori straordinari devono essere
indossabili quindi per quanto limitata
un'occasione d'uso speciale la
funzionalità di questi produttiva
progettata quindi anche una borsa di
sfilata in quanto borsa deve poter
contenere e trasportare qualcosa si deve
poter portare comodamente si deve poter
aprire e chiudere facilmente e in modo
sicuro da designer green non considero
ha corretto il progetto della più bella
clutch da sfilata nella quale però non
si possa inserire anche un rossetto o
che sia così pesante
da non poter essere indossata
comodamente per 5 minuti consecutivi
bisogna infatti ricordarsi quando si
progetta un accessorio che gli elementi
estetici e gli elementi funzionali non
sono antitetici
quindi si tratta di due aspetti che sono
compatibili e che insieme vanno a
costruire quello che ha un buon progetto
il design e quindi straordinario quando
riesce a tradurre una funzione in una
forma gradevole o riesce a rendere
funzionali e pratici degli oggetti che
hanno un grande fascino a livello
estetico
tutto questo è relativamente facile
nell'alto di gamma perché qui le
lavorazioni sono artigianali materiali
sono pregiati e tutto questo consente in
maniera relativamente semplice di dar
vita dei prodotti straordinari
quello che però è ancora più
affascinante nel lavoro di un designer e
la capacità di calare questa
straordinarietà dell'accessorio nella
realtà quotidiana
quindi con un occhio a quella che
l'industrializzazione del prodotto
infatti solo con l'innovazione del
processo produttivo da parte del
creativo si può garantire un prodotto di
qualità a un prezzo accessibile ai più
credo infatti fermamente che il ruolo
del designer di moda si stia evolvendo i
creativi sempre di più si devono
allontanare da una visione autoriferita
e da un approccio puramente estetico al
prodotto questo non basta più
nel futuro il designer si focalizzerà
sempre di più sul ruolo funzionale
dell'abbigliamento e dell'accessorio con
l'obiettivo di rispondere a delle
esigenze espresse o latenti del
consumatore
il prodotto quindi sarà progettato dando
sempre più rilevanza a quegli aspetti di
performance e di comfort si dovrà
ragionare sul valore generato per il
consumatore in termini di funzioni
assolte oltre che di conferimento di
status o come diceva prima di
definizione dell'identità attraverso
l'estetica quindi il buon progetto sarà
sempre meno valutato in base alla
bellezza estetica all'armonia delle
proporzioni
e verrà un po data per scontata la
capacità di un designer di generare
degli oggetti belli
la variabile invece che porterà più
vantaggio competitivo un prodotto
rispetto ad un altro sarà quella
capacità progettata di gestire delle
situazioni problematiche in modo
innovativo
quindi la borsa più comoda e più
funzionale per esempio per spostarsi in
moto la valigia che più agevolmente ci
aiuta a superare i controlli di
sicurezza in aeroporto questi stanno
diventando i criteri cruciali per la
scelta di un prodotto rispetto a un
altro da parte di un consumatore
quindi per questo si sta accentuando
sempre di più all'interno delle
organizzazioni il ruolo strategico del
design che diventerà proprio un elemento
fondante delle strategie aziendali con
l'obiettivo principale di generare
innovazione e differenziarsi dai
competitor tutto questo non solo
nell'ambito dell'abbigliamento e
dell'accessorio ma soprattutto in altri
settori dall automotive al food in
generale si sente quindi sempre di più
l'esigenza di un approccio creativo che
si è incentrato sugli obiettivi
aziendali da un lato e sulle esigenze
del consumatore dall'altro quindi il
sarà l'incontro tra il bello e
funzionale
l'accattivante e l'innovativo a generare
valore quindi la bellezza salverà il
mondo ma solo se i designer riusciranno
a innovare il processo produttivo ea
interpretare le esigenze delle persone
con lo scopo di migliorarne la vita
quotidiana attraverso dei prodotti ben
progettati e la qualità e il valore
viaggeranno indipendentemente dal
posizionamento prezzo
il progetto straordinario quindi non è
il costosissimo virtuosismo da sfilata
ma il accessorio performante che riesce
meglio a eliminare un disagio o generare
confort straordinaria infatti quelli da
innovativa che riesce a rendere migliore
il quotidiano grazie
[Applauso]